Simplifica "xy" elevado a la potencia - 2 que multiplica
a "2x" cuadrada sobre "y" cuadrada,
todo eso elevado a la cuarta potencia.
Veamos que podemos hacer con esto,
hagamos primero esta parte,
para esto vamos a utilizar algo que ya sabemos,
que si tenemos "x" sobre "y" elevado a la potencia "n",
esto es igual a "x" a la "n"
sobre "y" a la "n".
Apliquemos eso a esta expresión,
aquí tenemos "2x" cuadrada sobre "y" cuadrada,
elevado a la cuarta potencia.
Aplicando esa propiedad tenemos
"2x" cuadrada elevado a la cuarta sobre "y" cuadrada, también elevado a la cuarta potencia,
aún tenemos aquí "x" por "y" elevado a la -2.
Voy a empezar a simplificar esta expresión,
usando la siguiente propiedad
si tenemos "x" por "y" elevado a la "n",
esto equivale a tomar cada uno de estos factores,
elevarlos a la "n" y luego multiplicarlos,
así que esto es igual a "x" a la "n", por "y" a la "n",
de hecho si realizas esta operación de multiplicar
"x" por "y" "n" veces por sí mismo,
puedes reacomodar los términos para tener
"x" multiplicado por si mismo "n" veces
y "y" multiplicado por sí mismo "n" veces.
Entonces aplicando esta propiedad a "x" por "y"
elevado a la -2,
eso va a ser exactamente igual a "x" a la -2 por "y" a la -2.
Y ahora,
¿qué podemos simplificar?
Bien podemos usar esta propiedad de nueva cuenta, aquí donde tenemos 2x cuadrada elevado a la cuarta,
esto es equivalente
entonces a 2 elevado a la cuarta...
2 elevado a la cuarta que multiplica a "x" cuadrada elevado a la cuarta,
y eso dividido entre
"y" cuadrada elevado a la cuarta,
para esto vamos a usar una propiedad distinta.
Vamos a usar la propiedad que dice que si tengo "x",
elevado a la potencia "n"
y eso elevado a la potencia "m",
esto es igual a "x" elevado a la potencia "n" por "m".
Así es que aquí "y" elevado al cuadrado,
y elevado a la cuarta,
es lo mismo que tener "y" elevado a la 2 por 4.
Es decir, es igual a
"y" elevado a la octava potencia
y aquí tenemos "x" elevado a la -2 por "y" elevado a la -2,
para esto veamos
¿qué significa "x" elevado a la -2 y "y" elevado a la -2 ?
"x" elevado a la -2
es igual a 1 sobre "x" cuadrada,
"y" elevado a -2 es igual a 1 sobre "y" cuadrada,
así es que este término se convierte en...
así es que este término que está multiplicando aquí es, 1 sobre "x" cuadrada por 1 sobre "y" cuadrada,
que también podemos escribir como
1 sobre "x" cuadrada "y" cuadrada.
Y ahora lo último que vamos a hacer...
no, creo que no,
creo que hay un par de cosas más que hay que hacer.
Vamos a resolver aquí
"x" cuadrada elevado a la cuarta.
Vamos a usar esta propiedad
"x" cuadrada elevada a la cuarta,
esto va a ser igual "x" a la 2 por 4,
es decir,
esto de aquí equivale a "x" a la octava,
esto es exactamente igual a "x"
elevado a la octava potencia,
y este 2 elevado a la cuarta que tenemos aquí,
es, 2 al cubo es 8, 8 por 2 = 16,
esto equivale a 16.
Y ahora voy a hacer este producto.
Multiplico numerador por numerador
y denominador por denominador,
para obtener 1 por 16,
16 que multiplica a "x" a la octava
y todo eso dividido entre...
aquí tenemos
"x" cuadrada...
eso dividido entre "x" cuadrada
por "y" cuadrada, por "y" a la octava,
aquí podemos usar esta propiedad,
"y" cuadrada por "y" a la octava
esto es igual a "y" elevado a la 2 más 8...
"y" elevado a la 2 más 8,
que es igual a "y" elevado a la décima potencia.
Así es que esto es
"y" elevado a la décima potencia.
Y casi hemos terminado,
nos falta simplificar una cosa más.
Aquí tenemos "x" a la octava, sobre "x" cuadrada
y sabemos...
aquí voy a escribir la propiedad en general.
Si tenemos "x" a la "m" sobre "x" a la "n",
esto es igual a "x" a la "m" menos "n".
Así es que aquí que tenemos "x" a la octava,
sobre "x" cuadrada,
esto es igual a "x" a la 8 menos 2,
y esto es igual a "x" a la sexta.
Así es que finalmente nuestra expresión
simplificada, es igual a...
16 que multiplica a "x" a la sexta...
16 por "x" a la sexta dividido entre
"y" elevado a la décima potencia,
"y" a la décima,
y así hemos terminado.